hello
i'm stefan and
today i'm going to be talking about
relating semi-algebraic proofs and
various forms of geometric methods of
computation uh this is joint work with
mikagos noah fleming and robert rivera
so let's get started with extension
complexity so the concept here is if you
have a polytope in lower dimensions with
a set number of facets it might be
easier to have a higher dimensional
polytope with fewer defining facets and
that projects down to it so for example
in this image here we have a lower
dimensional polytope p
with eight facets whereas there is a
higher dimensional polytope p prime that
projects down to it linearly which has a
smaller set of descriptive
inequalities
and so why might this be an interesting
concept well it is useful for speeding
up linear programming if you were to
optimize over p this would take longer
than optimizing over p prime and then
projecting downwards
now this whole concept came about in the
1980s when yanukakis was trying to solve
the problem of refuting increasingly
esoteric linear programs that people
were conjuring to prove that p equals np
so we wanted to prove that say the
traveling salesman polytope
had exponential extension complexity
thereby automatically refuting
any and all linear programs that people
might come up with
so we're going to be studying uh
extended formulations and complexity for
pairs of polytopes so let p and q be two
polytopes where p is contained in q and
an extended formulation k of this pair
is a polytope that lives in higher
dimensions
and projects in between the two so in
this picture here we have p the inner
polytope uh q the outer polytope and k
which uh projects downwards in between
the two so containing p and a subset of
q
and we can formally define extension
complexity as minimizing over every
extended formulation of the pair pq on
the number of defining inequalities
and so this this uh is an interesting
concept however it's difficult to work
with with just this minimization so we
would like a more concrete uh way to
handle extension complexity a
combinatorial representation
so in order to do that i need to define
a matrix the slack matrix uh where for
again our two polytopes p and q p
contained in q
will have the vertices of p v 1 through
v n and the defining facets of q
a 1 x less than or equal to b 1 up to a
m x less than equal to v m and from this
we get the slack matrix
which is a non-negative matrix that
contains as elements uh the distances
from the vertices of p to the facets of
q
and so a beautiful theorem from
yanukakis
in 1988 is that
uh the non-negative rank of the slack
matrix
is in fact equivalent and completely
encapsulates extension complexity
so our goal is going to be understanding
extension complexity uh as actually a
circuit model for computing boolean
functions yanukakis
did this briefly in the original paper
by showing that you can simulate
boolean gates by inequalities so for
example we see here we can convert a not
gate to a single inequality uh as well
as or and and gates to sequence of
inequalities giving us that if we have a
boolean circuit of size s we can get an
extended formulation as well of big o of
s
uh so let's actually dive into a model
of computation and for that we need a
separating polytope so for a boolean
function f a separating polytope p of f
is a polytope that contains the convex
hall of the ones and has an empty
intersection with the zeros now this was
first
loosely considered by yanukakis and then
was more formally defined by paul rubish
so uh here is just a pictorial
description of a separating polytope uh
inside we have the complex hall of the
ones of f uh p which contains this
convex hall and has an empty
intersection with the zeros of f
uh now as well we can define a
separating polytope for monotone boolean
functions and it would look something
like this however it takes a bit of
technicality to fully define so i will
leave that
all right let's jump into an actual
non-uniform model of computation and
this was introduced by rubesh in 2012
uh and to do that we're going to be
taking
use of the extension complexity so we're
going to want an extended formulation
that as an as a separating polytope and
in order to do that we need an outer
polytoe we have an inner polytope of the
convex hall of the ones of f and we need
an outer polytope and we define an
example of an outer polytope here and
we'll do this using karcher and vigorous
inequalities so let's define this
polytope qf1
where we define an inequality for every
zero of f
of this sum from i 1 to n of x i by 1
minus y i plus 1 minus x i by y i is at
least 1.
now on the left-hand side this is
actually equivalent to the hamming
distance between 2 boolean strings x and
y and on the right hand side we have at
least one
because any one of f
is going to have to have at least
hamming distance one between any zero of
f
so victoria we see this below uh we have
the convex hell of the ones and the
inequalities of qf1 are fleshed right up
against
the convex hull
so again we can actually do this for
monotone boolean functions
and here we can just drop uh the
the latter part of the sum here because
we know that f is monotone
now since all we care about is a
separating polytope uh between the ones
and the zeros we actually don't
necessarily need a one as in qf1 we can
do it for any positive epsilon
and so when you do that we get this new
outer polytope qf epsilon where instead
of having a 1 over here on the right
hand side of the inequality we have an
epsilon
and pictorially below we see that this
gives more space
than qf1 had so potentially you could
have
a smaller extension complexity of some
polytope that lies between the convex
hull of the ones and qf epsilon then you
might have with qf1
and so we can see that here with qf1
being right up against convexol and
qf-epsilon
giving more breathing room
so we uh we can as rubish did define
formal complexity measures here uh with
separation complexity so on the
left-hand side we have step one of f
this being the non-negative rank of the
slack matrix minus one and we have a
monotone version as well and on the
right-hand side we have separation
complexity of f being the minimization
overall uh epsilon larger than zero of
the non-negative rank of the slack
matrix mice epsilon and likewise a
monotone version and we minimize epsilon
here just so we can find truly uh the
best extended formulation we have as a
separating polytope between the ones and
the zeros
and a nice uh property here as rubesh
proved is that these complexity measures
are not that esoteric
in fact
sept1 lower bounds formula size and
separation complexity lower bounds
circuit size
and just to nail it in uh by the ionic
caucasus factorization theorem uh the
nice way to write separation complexity
i would also be minimizing our epsilon
of the extension complexity of this pair
the convex hall of the ones and qf
epsilon
so now we would like to analyze query
and proof complexity
versions of this exact analysis
so let's start off with our first
semi-algebraic proof system conical
hunter degree and all we're going to be
doing here is introducing a way to give
a certificate that a polynomial is
non-negative
so we'll work over variables x1 through
xn and let's take s a subset of the
indices one through n and t a subset of
the complement
uh then a junta is just going to be a
product that represents a conjunction so
what do i mean by that if we have a
conjunction here x1 and not x2 and x3
and x4 well this would give the
corresponding junta where we take all
the positive variables and the
conjunction and to multiply it
positively here and then we take the
negative variable which is x2 and
multiply it as one minus that variable
here
now conocohunta is just going to be a
conical sum of juntas so what that is is
just taking non-negative coefficients uh
and multiplying them to hunters and
making a sum
so now we can actually make a complexity
measure out of this
we can call it conical hunter degree as
deg plus and this will be the minimal
degree such that we have a conical
hundred representation of f
and as a reminder
if we have such a representation of f
then this is a certificate that f is
non-negative
now for we actually kind of seen this
already uh where for extension
complexity uh a slack matrix is
non-negative and making that uh
factorization of the slack matrix into a
sum of non-negative uh rank 1 matrices
is a proof of that non-negativity
and we're actually going to do the same
thing here but for a polynomial and
we're going to show it's non-negative by
factoring into a sum of juntas
so what is that polynomial going to be
it's going to be
the number of violations so if we have
c to be an unsatisfiable cnf uh then we
define this polynomial here the
violations of c to be the sum over the
negations of the clauses and on an input
this is going to count the number of
violated clauses
uh now if we can show that this
polynomial is non-negative specifically
greater than zero uh then that means
we've proven that our cnf is
unsatisfiable so we would like to prove
that vial of c minus epsilon uh is
larger uh or equal to zero for some
epsilon
this giving a certificate that the cnf
is unsatisfiable
okay so if we do a shrub style
minimization as we saw for separation
complexity
for
for conical hunter degree perhaps this
is interesting to examine and it turns
out that this is equal to something
quite natural it is equal to shirley
adams degree
so shirali adams is another crew system
a generalization of conical hunter
degree
again it's um it's a certificate
um that the cnf is unsatisfiable and uh
really what's going on underneath is you
can think of it also as a hierarchy of
polytopes that converges to an empty
integral hull for an unsatisfiable cnf
and the this proof system is also well
studied as a an analysis for using
linear programming uh to give as an
approximation algorithm
so let's actually see uh shirley adams
refutations what that is is given a cnfc
uh a refutation is a list of conical
hunters j1 through gm plus one we're on
the left hand side we have the negated
clauses
with a minus one multiplied by these
conical hunters plus an additional
conical hunter here equals minus one and
why this is a refutation is because the
left-hand side is non-negative whereas
the right-hand side is minus one
uh so we can define again a complexity
measure here uh shirley adams degree as
the minimal degree d appearing for any
shirali adam's refutation of c and we
can also define size as the minimal
number of monomials we need for a chiral
atom's refutation of c
before cancellation
and if you'd like to see more
specifically on lower bounds or other
semi-algebraic proof systems i recommend
seeing no fleming's survey on chiralia
atoms and other semialgebraic pure
systems
so our results well we already saw
that this rubish-like minimization of
conical hunter degree on the violations
is equivalent to chirali adams degree
uh so we can also ask well if we have
conical hunter degree of vial
minus one
uh does this actually differ uh from
minimizing vial minus epsilon
so we know that
at least it is simulated by but can the
simulation go the other way and we
answer to that
negatively
we show that there is a
family of formulas
that resolution can easily prove uh
whereas it cannot be done in low degree
for conical hunter degree
uh some more specifically the conical
hunter degree of the violations of this
iteration family minus one is at least
linear
and iteration here is just an
unsatisfiable family of cns representing
the house sitting principle
okay so likewise we can use lifting to
apply all this to
circuit complexity classes uh
specifically separation complexity and
we're able to separate monotone circuit
complexity from
m sub 1.
this again shows that m step is strictly
stronger than m sub one
and uh
the way we do this is we use kmr lifting
kothari mecca ragavendra
showed that you are able to lift conical
hub to degree to non-negative rank and
so that we are able to take our results
for chirali adam's degree and lift it to
separation complexity
so here all results in one picture we
have our separations and lifting
and we also showed feasible
interpolation uh meaning that we can
take the proof system uh we can take a
refutation ashrael adams refutation uh
and convert it into
a computational model that simulates it
uh so we have some a simulation of
chirali adam's degree by monotone
separation complexity and this was first
examined by hakone miyami um but his uh
his feasible interpolation was slightly
different where he feasibly interpolated
shirali adams by a proof search
algorithm rather than monotone
separation complexity
okay so let's actually dive in to one of
our results namely the classification
theorem uh so we want to show that
shirley adams degree is equivalent to
this minimization
uh so let's first uh look at a near
proof of this result um in this lemma
here so if you were to have a c and f on
m clauses and and variables and if we
were to have a very special uh r shirley
adams reputation namely that the
the negated clauses are not multiplied
by anything uh other than real
coefficients
uh if we were to have such a
shareliana's refutation of degree d and
size s
as well as bounded coefficients uh one
over epsilon at most
uh then this means that we also get um
vile the violations of c minus epsilon
is a conical hunter
specifically this kanako hunter will
also have degree d so no blow up on
degree and
multiplied by 2 for size
so this is nearly what we want except in
general a chirali adams refutation is
going to multiply
our clauses our negative clauses by
conoco juntas so somehow in our main
proof we're going to have to get rid of
those
all right and that's exactly what we're
going to do so let's start with a normal
shirali adam's reputation degree d and
size s and we're going to expand the
conical hunters into monomials
so
when you expand it'll look exactly like
this where the alpha k's are real
coefficients and we have our negated
clauses sometimes appearing more than
once and we have monomials mk and it
will have
in addition a conical hunter added to
the side
equaling minus one and so we'll need a
brief fact that if you were to sum over
all of these conical juntas summing
specifically over subsets of the indices
one through n
of the hunter
of s and the complement
then this in fact equals one and this is
a very simple proof by induction
uh so given that fact let's run through
an example to see how this proof will
work and we'll use uh the monomial mu
being just the product of x i's from
indices 1 through l
and notice that this is actually
equivalent to this junta here uh where
we have one through l uh
multiplied positively and no variables
multiplied negatively
okay so if we were uh to reverse
engineer what we need then we would
start with a minus a negated clause so
of course this equals minus the negated
clause times one and by our fact we can
expand out the one
uh to be minus our negative clause times
this sum
and so on the first part of the sum is
just mu as we noticed above
and on the second part of the sum we
have a conical hunter so writing this
down below we have minus ci bar times mu
minus uh ci bar times the kanako hunter
and because ci bar itself is a
conjunction uh this actually makes uh
this entire thing a konica junta so if
we were to try and get rid of mu then
we're able to do that just by dragging
this
conical hunter out into the conical
hunter portion of our proof
and so all you need to do to finish this
theorem is to repeat this for every
single monomial and what we'll get as a
result is a degree d size s to the two
to the d uh times two to the d conical
hunter and if we apply apply the lemma
we had earlier
then this is all we need to finish our
proof
so just to summarize everything we've
seen so far
we gave a rhubash-like analysis of
semi-algebraic proof systems where we
did a minimization and saw what that
equaled in fact if you did this
minimization of
uh conical hunter degree this gets you
shirley adams degree and interestingly
the epsilon we saw for that minimization
corresponds to
coefficient size
as well we separated a conical 100
degree
from chirali adams degree
and
we also separated m sub 1 by with m sep
by lifting
and uh i briefly mentioned as well that
we feasibly interpolated shirley adams
degree by monotone separation complexity
i'd also like to note that all of the
arguments we saw for the
characterization and feasible
interpolation uh those also work for
sums of squares
so there there are some open problems
that are very interesting um
after this work so the main thing is we
would very much like to improve uh the
kothari mecca ragaventra lifting that we
need of conical hunted degree
to non-negative rank and the reason
being is if you actually write out uh
the lifting theorem you have this very
pesky 1 over 100 n
that appears
and so the problem with this is that we
want to show equivalence of these
complexity measures uh but we can't at
least we need a sufficiently large
epsilon to do so uh so it would be very
nice to get rid of this 1 over 100 n
in the proof of this lifting theorem
so next
we have another open problem on some
objects i didn't define so far um we
would like to separate weak mlp gates
from strong nlp gates uh now what are
these uh well in oliveira and public
they defined circuits with gates defined
by monotone linear programs
and they showed that uh well there are
these two different kinds of gates uh
weak meaning that your input will only
affect a one of
the objective function or the defining
inequalities and strong your input will
affect both
they showed that a single weak gate
is equivalent to monotone separation
complexity
and a circuit of strong gates actually
feasibly interpolates the best driver
and
this separation between weak and strong
gates is quite interesting uh especially
since uh we've shown in this paper
that weak mlp gates in fact interpolate
shirley adams degree
well thank you for listening